show et this oestrus hey hey listen the
moment of the night when you gave a bear
hug like I've never seen before
I jumped in as Sam Jackson's arms
I had hops the Jordans gotta be the
shoes what does this mean to you sir to
hold this after this illustrious career
you've had whoa I got 20 more years so
uh hopefully be back one day for you
it's a win for Brooklyn New York
whoever Brooklyn New York there anyone
you didn't think that you want to thank
now I had to be honest I had two
speeches one which I said and another
one was for that thanks but I said I
might not be up here again is I better
say my speech how will you celebrate
tonight what time do you think we can
expect you in your bed tonight
I'm going to jay-z Beyonce look I'm not
showing shade on Vanity Fair so great
but fern after-after-party you know at
this so uh I got a I got a little my my
my booking brother jay-z but it's a
great night great night a great night
for you congratulations that was so
great to see your joy up there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]